yeah and I hope a real good shake-up you
know that tornado that came through my
neighborhood I hope he comes through the
show honey we're still trying to recover
Leeanne Locken telling ET she's ready
for a cast shake-up on the Real
Housewives of Dallas I think if I could
give anyone anything I would love to get
maybe a few of my cast members a little
more security it's been a rollercoaster
season for the reality star she's
currently facing allegations of being
racist toward a co-star Carrie
Brittingham she's a bully I think that I
genuinely everything I do in my life
anybody who knows me anywhere around the
country from WeHo to Dallas knows that I
believe in inclusion and equality and I
will fight and die for making that
happen and I don't know how you can have
that label and an ally label and I tell
you what I love my ally label and I'll
never lose it
Leeanne will get to unpack all that at
the season 4 reunion oh I have so many
things to clear up I don't think there's
a number one for me I mean that's what
happens when you're like the you know
the the target signing it you there's
more than one there's layers so like the
bullseye obviously would be the label
they're trying to get me but you know
there's still outer rims of my
negativity or this or that you know I
have a lot of really great points I'm
excited to make and I
really can't wait to make them eg spoke
with Leanne at the Daily Mail's holiday
party in New York City where she shared
her own Christmas season plans you know
what I honestly what I spend all my time
for the holiday season is doing charity
I'm gonna go home I've got the stocking
auction for legacy counseling on Sunday
as soon as I hit the ground and it's
just gonna be party party party party
party paying it forward this is the time
of the year while we're all thinking
about having a good time make sure we
think about everyone that isn't and try
to pay it just a little forward
[Music]